-You guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually when I
catch up on personal stuff.
I check my inbox.
I return some emails.
And I, of course,
send out thank you notes.
I'm was just running
a bit behind.
I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind,
can I write out my weekly
thank you notes
right now for you guys?
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Laughter ]
That's my dude right there.
♪♪
Thank you, bobsledding, for
being competitive Uber pooling.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get in, get in.
-Two-man luge.
-Nice to meet you.
-Double luge.
♪♪
-Thank you, curling,
for being the only sport
in the world where world
class athletes can train
by Swiffering their kitchen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
When's J. Lo coming out?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-When's J. Lo coming out?
-Soon.
We've got to do this bit, yeah.
-You gotta do this bit first?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, ski jumping,
for being the flying
squirrel of Olympic sports.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you, free style skiers,
for being so good at skiing
that you look like
you're bad at skiing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah!
Hey!
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
cross country skiing,
or as I like to call you,
complicated walking.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you,
new Olympic sport monobob,
for not going by your more
accurate title, batmobiling.
That would be cool.
[ Applause ]
-Monobob?
-Thank you,
passing the Olympic torch,
for basically being
the world's largest,
"Hey, you got a light?"
There you guys have it.
Those are the "Thank You Notes."